moi l'école
[Applaudissements]
la la la la la
ah la la
les chansons facile-facile bodart départ
bien que ni la tour des villes nous que
tu te dis que tu te prends bien là
cela fait donc cela
[Musique]
le tous ensemble en champ droit du caire
on prend 2,7 vote chanter sa
[Musique]
chanson
il en veut
tant que voix
pas si jeune
e
non non non
ah la la
c'est tout ouais
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas bien du tout
c'est beaucoup
certaines d'habitants
david bastien ça qu'on gagne un siège et
je tenais vraiment ma place avant tout à
fait je le connais très bien c'est un
garçon david rudisha et met le sosie de
quelqu'un d'aussi alors à temps fuchs
explique quand il a décidé un jour
d'abord quand il a dit un jour il
voulait être sosie de claude françois il
avait acheté la perruque et les mecs
lourds dit tu ressembles à ses vols à la
merci merci david à bientôt
david oui reste dans le coin parce que
si si sébastien nous fait un ménard qui
peut être à sa place ça évitera d'imphy
d'abord à le faire tu sais quand tu en
voilà
[Applaudissements]
pato surgelés revient à merde on revient
car plus les lieux tu recycle
voilà bah tu rigoles ou quoi ce moment
mais je les adore attend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est le warm up
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors quand des tweets le 10 octobre
réagissez sur l'émission hashtag à ciel
tu es sur twitter voilà je voulais
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé là la
semaine dernière voilà je m'excuse
thierry je pensais que j'étais
humoristes en fait je veux juste partir
les invités impulsion au le pot voilà si
vous avez un cerisier dans votre jardin
appelez moi cet été voilà pourquoi que
les moineaux vous emmerde n'hésitez pas
voilà donc maintenant les tweets alors
on va reprendre le même tweet que la
semaine dernière il y avait anthony la
semaine dernière qui nous demandait à
aston villa chaque semaine je suis mort
de rire pendant le cdd il n'y a jamais
personne qui prend mal les vannes dans
salut les terres et si on l'a tous vu
voilà ce qui s'est passé bruno solo
c'est beaucoup vexé sur la pub
seloger.com est bon c'est des choses qui
arrivent on va faire un petit débrief
des tweets sur la sphère robert ménard
ya thomas qui nous dit ménard se barre
de salut les terriens je reconnais qu'il
avait raison la vanne avec adolphe était
celle de trop de david villa il ya une
limite
il a cru que j'étais footballeur david
villa c'est le footballeur voilà moi cet
homme sait pas c'est pas grave un autre
tweet deux ferrari 84 qui nous dit je
suggère que tom villa présente des
excuses à adolphe sax à saint-aignan
être comparé à ménard le pauvre la voile
alors je m'excuse auprès de la famille
d'adolphe sax que j'ai pu offenser voilà
étais rires tu avais rien demandé qui
s'en sont pris plein la gueule par ma
faute et on fait également du coût par
la même occasion à gros bisous à tous
les saxophones qui nous regardent
laurent ournac qu'on embrasse et qui me
dit sur twitter tommy là j'ai une maison
de famille à côté de béziers tu passes
quand tu veux
c'est gentil mais pas tout de suite
parce que c'est trop tôt que on va
propose de faire l'ouverture de la feria
ils sont trente mille sur la place
j'ai fait il ya deux ans c'était
formidable et une ambiance
extraordinaire est là c'est pas les
taureaux qui vont de course et à mon
avis pas
[Applaudissements]
après on va pas se mentir j'ai eu mon
stylo d' insulte que je vais vous lire
ce soir je vais pas vous dire que voilà
sinon on finira à 22h30 j'ai mis les
plus créatifs casque jaune me dis ta
mère c'est une grosse [ __ ] [ __ ] de
bosch c'est une blague j'ai le droit et
comment il ya l'info le monde
[Applaudissements]
alors juste les quatre marques
remarquant juste que casque jaune aime
le vin la france et les tracteurs il est
membre du front national et qu'il est
suivie par marine le pen
voilà bon hein y'a thiery de paris sur
twitter qui nous dit petit crevure de
tom villa tas de merde ordures si tu te
fais choper à béziers est passé à tabac
ça sera bien mérité râler mais c'est
drôle que ça soit thierry de paris qui
parle le béziers
c'est pas vous tirez pour nous deux je
sais pas au voyage
mais j'ai des gens il faut sans témoin
ouais et en termine avec le dernier
truite de valmont qui nous dit tom villa
troubadours vous plutôt trou du cul et
sans ménard vous évoque un certain adolf
vous fait penser à une certaine zahia
alors non moi j'avais été zahia joulie
il y aurait eu beaucoup moins de
problèmes en équipe de france
c'est vrai
et puis on termine ce que vous le
permettez tirée par un petit tweet plus
léger le tweed de notre laurent baffie
préféré qui nous a parlé de la primaire
sur twitter de la droite avec la
victoire de fillon sur juppé et laurent
nous est dit primaire de droite la
guerre des fromages caprice des dieux
vient d' [ __ ] chaussée
n'hésitez pas à réagir à l'émotion
voilà ses pieds noirs m
[Applaudissements]
on passe à salut les terriens
[Musique]
ap
l'intérieur se tient bien vous dans
votre tour du samedi soir bonsoir très
heureux de nous retrouver sur ses
désormais pour ardisson est belle vie
tapez si bien avec vous ce soir quatre
derrière le choix patrick sébastien
[Applaudissements]
sebastian est là messieurs le dernier
des grands shows mène de la télé pour le
public est le dernier des emmerdeurs
pour la direction de france 2
autre qu'alain invité ce soir c'est mon
invité tt ou de la semaine mais aussi
mon invité mais ça fait combien de temps
que tu es pas le nom mais sérieux tu
faisais la gueule ou pas c'est mon
premier salut les terriens pierre
bellemare
[Musique]
autres claironne invité ce soir
l'héroïne de jour polaire
la nouvelle série de canal celle qui
donne envie de s'abonner
comme kara morgan à l'époque les
l'appétit
[Applaudissements]
autres terriens invité ce soir il est
drôle il est gay mais il n'a pas épousé
véronique sanson jarry
[Musique]
on paie de vous accueillir notre grand
invité d'honneur de la semaine philippe
starck voix l'émission s'appelle salut
les terriens le gros le gréement de
fortune et le hashtag c'est insulter
[Musique]
alors lyrique bouger un petit peu
spécial dans le décor cette semaine
c'est une bougie de l'unicef vous pouvez
trouver de nombreuses idées de cadeaux
comme cette bougie sur le site de
l'unicef fait du bien en faisant plaisir
et maintenant voici mon cdd comme villa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savatier tout va bien très très beau
plateau ce soir et je tiens à le
préciser on va ce match et
on va se coucher tu es sur moi je fais
partir les invités toi tu dis des
insanités allez
ma part si j'ai autant de talent pour
faire fuir les invités pierre palmade
bonjour ça va en q les
photos parlent encore trop tôt comme
d'habitude
pierre palmade bonjour bonjour vous
naissez de 24 mars 67 à libourne 23 à
bordeaux vous avez deux frères deux
soeurs
votre mère était prof de maths et votre
père vétérinaire non ma mère est prof
d'anglais mon père est mort
d'accord petit vous passez votre temps
dans les jupes de votre mère est très
vite vous tombez amoureux d'elle adultes
vous l'a demandée en mariage et
désespéré par son refus vous épousez
france gall donc
ça c'est vrai donc vous débourserez huit
jours plus tard pour convoler en
deuxièmes noces avec arlette chabot
c'est bon quand ça va en 96 vous faites
votre coming out et vous avouer chez
mireille dumas votre penchant pour les
poneys shetland
et la vitamine c
pauli une magnifique femelle de 7 ans
vous donnera deux beaucoup l'un - qui
finira deuxième au grand prix jean luc
lahaye du jardin d'acclimatation
ça c'est ce qu'on fait non non non
[Applaudissements]
patrick sébastien bonjour coach laurent
malgré votre voix de merde et vos textes
à chier vous sentez un nouvel album qui
s'appelle retiens qu'on doit que je pète
[Applaudissements]
la nuit on s'en fout il ya le sosie
samba mais j'y arrive pas c'est un
boulot c'est un vrai boulot
[Applaudissements]
bon patrick sébastien rebond soir ont
fait en 60 ans patrick il a essayé
toutes les coupes de cheveux non en
rester à ce niveau
ou alors c'est une caisse mais sinon
c'est plus générale face à
apple ces raccords
jamais dans l'esprit de
sérieux je déteste le scato
donc patrick sébastien en 60 ans patrick
vous avez essayé toutes les coupes de
cheveux se mentir la soixante trois ans
vous êtes bien c'est entre michael
douglas et sophie davant leurs
18 ans maintenant que ça dure le plus
grand cabaret du monde vous avez proposé
le droit de faire l'adaptation en chine
ouais et vous avez refusé ouais pour
l'année de la chine ils m'ont proposé de
faire devant un milliard de
téléspectateurs le plus riche qu'avant
je suis pas y aller parce que je prends
pas l'avion non mais c'est classe de sa
part après c'est vrai que pour une fois
que les chinois demande avant de copier
la couverte un épi là où vous venez pour
une boîte de jeux de société le mec il a
un truc en tête il le fait s'est dit
tiens j'aime les apéros les jeux de
société les sardines par moi qui ai une
idée non bah du coup vous avez créé un
jeu de société en droite de haut en
forme de boîte à tartines voilà pour les
apéros on a de la chance qu'ils n'aiment
pas les lampes les maladies vénériennes
et bassila sur les tablettes des dieux
mais
si mal
notre deuxième à l'itc pierre palmade
pierre je
[Applaudissements]
tiens je laime du fond du coeur c'est
l'un de ceux voilà qui m'a donné petit
envie de faire ce métier ça faisait onze
ans que qu on vous attendait dans salut
les terriens
numéro on a je pense que nous notre côté
on a aussi attendu la meilleure période
capillaires pour vous
non mais ça c'est le problème des années
c'est le voilà les mecs se coiffer que
des réacteurs d'airbus à l'époque c'est
d'écrire je n'étais même pas à la mode
j'étais déjà des monnaies c'est vrai
voilà j'étais ou en avance ou en retard
mais j'étais pas à mon époque pierre
c'est le fondateur aussi de la troupe à
palmade formidable qui a révélé
pêle-mêle anne elisabeth blateau
qualicoat arnaud tsamère vous recruter
encore bailleurs ou pas on est 40 c'est
pas pour moi mais parce que le week-end
dernier avec les primaires de droiture
la con perdu leur job je me dis qu'il ya
peut-être un coup à jouer
et puis pierre palmade c'est aussi le
célèbre duo avec michèle laroque voile
ça fait 20 ans que vous êtes en couple
sur scène avec michèle laroque vous
tapez les engueulades les repas de
famille les crises de nerfs la et au
final c'est françois baroin qui cela
tapez donc voilà ça c'est de vous adorez
et vous avez dit dans une interview
pierre j'ai eu quatre ou cinq femmes
dans ma vie c'est fou parce que vous
sachiez pas le nombre exact parce que
moi si j'avais eu des mecs dans ma vie
vous assurer que je serai à 500 le
nombre voire même le lieu et la date dix
élèves ben je m'en souviens
allez on termine notre tour de france de
la coiffure avec jalil mesdames et
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
jarry jarry qui grosso modo
capillairement se situe entre christophe
wilhem et arturo brachetti voilà le dvd
du spectacle vient de sortir jarry vous
allez jouer bientôt là tout le mois de
décembre à bobino jarry atypique je
précise l'humoriste et jarry est
atypique c'est le titre du spectacle si
on la plaint qu'on mélange est étonnant
et c'est vrai rires m'appelle s'enhardit
monsieur atypique away sidon ans et
j'arrive jarry qui en arabe la
signification ça veut dire mon voisin en
portugaise et la bûche
et jarry en sourds et malentendants ça
veut dire j'arrive tories
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou alors mais vous avez choisi ce pseudo
pour mon voisin évidemment franchement
je te le dis moi j'ai un voisin comme
toi je déménage direct mais oui tu cries
tu chantes si le buzz et cabaret de
sébastien en une seule personne c'est
alors non mais pour l'avoir vu je
recommande chaudement le spectacle juste
ce avec un petit conseil on dit toujours
que le premier rang s'en prend plein la
gueule glace et les dix premiers en
descendant la signal il fait des câlins
et des bisous eyes tactile s'assoit sur
les gens ah ouais il dit c'est dur non
mais en plus des fois on est surpris il
ya des biens meilleures prises tous les
soirs sur scène il embrasse un homme du
public voilà je signale juste qu'en ce
moment il ya une épidémie de gastro je
vous laisse deviner la source voilà est
l'une des émissions qui vous a fait
connaître c'est le vendredi tout est
permis voilà vous en effet beaucoup
peut-être même plus qu arthur je crois
est fermé
sur le contre pure elle est nickel et
pour cause elle une guerre sans merci au
point de seiche et aux cheveux cassants
c'est leïla bekhti mais la jeune
[Applaudissements]
leïla
j'aimerais pas être à votre place parce
qu'être belle h24 stress tortures
infligées à chacune de vos sorties
publiques les gens qui attendent qu'une
chose c'était plus sage et croiser betty
en prêt des patins alors que quand et
franck ribéry à moins de pression au
pire les gens ils disent vas tu sais
quoi je le croyais plus moche que ça
[Musique]
alors là vous venez nous voir parce que
vous faites partie du casting de la
nouvelle série de canal + ça s'appelle
jour polaire voilà vous jouez une
policière française qui enquêtent avec
un suédois sur un meurtre d'un français
autour du cercle polaire voilà déjà de
voir l'interrogatoire j'ai pas vu encore
la série mais j'ai vraiment pas d'air
t'imagines vous étiez où la nuit du
meurtre et si la nuit du 31 octobre au 2
avril vous étiez où c'est exactement là
en plus vous allez tourner tous deux
jours c'est pendant l'été polaire voilà
ce qui a permis à la production de ne
faire qu'un cachet d'une journée
oui c'est une vanne d'intermittents ça
c'est stop c'est la première
coproduction franco suédois c'est très
courageux d'avoir accepté payer moitié
en euros moitié en somme on vraiment
bravo et jour polaire je sais pas si
vous avez entendu il ya là la saison 2
qui va être en préparation ça s'appelait
jours scolaires ça fli qui déboule au
centre de formation du psg pour savoir
qui a tué la langue française
mais la mairie ce qui peut nous poser la
question futura buisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser c'est ça pierre
palmade avec jarre d'armand vous êtes
l'auteur des célèbres youtube préfère là
alors pierre palmade tu préfères avis
être suivie partout tout le temps par
carla bruni qui joue de la guitare ou
tous les matins te réveiller à côté de
jean jacques bourdin
non carla bruni kaffer qu'elle me
suivent qu'elle te suivent
leïla bekhti leïla bekhti vous est
l'égérie de voilà de l'oréal dont le
slogan est parce que je le vaux bien du
coup c'est que vous le valez combien
alors
jarry ja rien on l'a vu dans votre
spectacle que vous maniez très bien le
bâton de majorette c'est un atout dans
le métier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour terminer patrick sébastien patrick
voilà où je n'ai jamais caché vos
expériences dans les clubs échangistes
ça vous fait quoi de voir thierry de
face
[Applaudissements]
allez
elie gilbert
collard
les mauvaises langues
et on passe maintenant à notre thé au
top du top
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on avait été au top et quand est venu on
s'est dit attends on est plus que top
chef on a inventé au top du top
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
patrick sébastien rebond soir oui
monsieur ardisson alors t'as mis ma
fille est revenue à sa fin 1 alors en
préparant les missions j'ai retrouvé un
truc que laurent avait fait surtout à
l'époque de double jeu un costard de
stars non quand tu t'étais fait viré de
tf1
regarde non
j'ai fait aujourd'hui contre la télé
poubelle sauf quoi de voir un manifester
comme ça veut d'abord ça fait plusieurs
jours
qu'un télévision je vois pas dans le
monde connaissait les raisons de son
départ
manifestent contre les émissions les
nouvelles émissions qu'ils qualifient de
télé-poubelle genre perdu de vue et au
train oui je pense qu'ils doivent
horizons puisque vous avez quand même un
conte un message de soutien à peu de
sébastien
qu'est ce que je lui dis si vous
souhaitez qui reste à la télé dit lui
qua non
j'essaie de claques c'est cool tu crois
de la place pour un drôle de voir partir
de tf1 ça me fait de la peine il devrait
pas parce qu'elles sont molles ces
émissions sont très agréables à voir il
ya de bons acteurs et limites surtout
très bien y passer une imitation pardon
j'ai dit aux passionnés mutation hop
awards dans
les chaussettes talent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors patrick sur france 2 tout va bien
18e saison pour le plus grand cabaret du
monde plus les années bonheur
ça va inquiet parce que d'habitude quand
tu n'aimais sur marche qui la remplace
wallemme avait enlevé deux deux
caravanes
mais il ya des gens qui sont arrivés que
des nouvelles personnes et qui m'ont qui
vont redonner ses deux prime et comme
j'ai pas envie de faire la même chose
j'ai décidé de faire une nouvelle
émission en direct arrêt au mois de
février
au four va décoder ça va s'appeler sadni
folie's et on va tous se permettre à
wade et ceux qui ne m'aiment pas dit ce
que je suis capable du pire et ceux qui
m'aiment bien disent que je suis capable
du meilleur donc on va contenter tout le
monde
le mec il avait publié des chiffres les
deux tailles vincent bellay qui est déjà
parti alors vous dites il venait
d'arrêter et résultat il n'a créé que
des émissions qui font l'audience d'arte
et sam c'est un souvenir assez
douloureux pour moi laissez moi qui sont
passés qui fait quand tu étais obligé
d'aller dans les galas pour s'apercevoir
que les antennes bien parce que chez
trompe pas c'est un peu difficile rien
livre non mais ça le faisait chier de
commencer les réunions avec un petit
chat [ __ ]
dans mon truc c'est bien mon truc du
tout mais patino l'ancien patron avant
d'incendier très bien dans son bouquin
vous est ingérable pour lui c'est un
compliment gérable c'est ingérable non
j'ai pas complètement ingérable quand
même quoi vouloir continuer ce métier
parce que je n'aime pas ce que c'est ma
vie parce que je je vais mourir dans peu
de temps un jour je pense avec la vie
que j'ai menées et que je veux tomber
net je veux pas m'arrêter avant ça nous
attend mais jouer sur scène of tanks non
pas sur scène j'ai aussi les autographes
après
sa séquelle je viens je vis en sur
actifs prend pas de vacances du tout là
je pars faire un téléfilm j'écris mon
téléfilm je fais mes chansons mon album
sort l'album j'ai besoin de ça pour
exister voilà en gros patrick ça vous en
touche une sans faire bouger l'autre je
crois quand je crois qu'on peut le dire
c'est exactement ça ça va en touche
citation
c'est quoi la chorégraphie de celle là
c'est ça non mais ce cas de fou c'est
que la clientèle que j'ai maintenant
dans les galas ccd moom de 20 ans
déscolarisés la plupart oui mais qui ont
envie de ceux qui ont envie de s'amuser
et ballerines sert des geeks est ce que
c'est ça c'est du ska oui je sais que
c'est mal mais on remercie jamais c'est
maintenant la plupart de mes titres
c'est du scad jusqu'à non la plupart des
cas dit c'est de la merde
mais alors ça j'adore parce que ça fait
ça fait des années que j'entends ça et
moi ça me fait rire parce que tu as tout
un tas de chanteurs qui se la pète
qu'ils ont quand même pas faire de la
merde mais n'en fait pas surtout laissez
moi tout seul ne venez pas restez où
vous êtes faites vos belles chansons
laisser mon travail à moi
cette chanson est extrait du nouvel
album de patrick sébastien qui
s'appelait le sébastien nouveau est
arrivé alors c'est un disque formidable
qui va bien pourrir les mariages de
l'année prochaine qui est fait que pour
faire la folle de lui marié pas
alors vous avez arrêté de boire il ya 32
ans ça veut dire que ces chaussures la
voulait composer agen à gens sachent
tout ça j'ai découvert à attendre il ya
32 ans là le plaisir de la lucidité s'il
arrivait un litre et demi de whisky par
jour comme c'est bon j'ai découvert le
le la qualité de la lucidité qu'est ce
que c'est bien de faire les mêmes
conneries mais pas bourré plein de
lucidité en contrôle total samar el hajj
aux stars vous adore il a dit les
chansons de sébastien te reste dans la
tête pendant une semaine comme l'odeur
du grillon te colle à la cheville
on a été ensuite enfants on a enregistré
quant à yvonne à toulouse et
on s'est bien marré là il ya un truc moi
j'ai vu un truc dans le times c'est un
mec quelle est la chanson les sardines
dans la tête depuis un mois il a essayé
de se suicider quand il est mort son
oraison lui a dit qu'est-ce qu'on
essaierait au fond de cette boîte donc
ça s'appelle le sébastien nouveau est
arrivé on regarde aquasar sans
les brûler
les marchands de peine on n'en veut plus
provost battre des cent vallées
il est grand temps que nos histoires
[Musique]
mais c'est ce soir
les
foulées
pour se défouler
s
c'est ce soir allez
et qu'on n'en faut
ça
[Musique]
et
si ce soir extrait du dernier album de
patrick sébastien tour des tours d à
côté de béziers y en a une que j'aime
beaucoup aussi s'est fait tourner les
épouses
tu as trouvé ça ou vous pourriez
affaires sales alors
les paroles la musique
les les deux en même temps je suis
mélodiste c'est à dire j'avais honte
musique et paroles en même temps je
n'arrive jamais musiciens angers moi ça
on va travailler ensemble dessus et
c'est dur et bonheur parce que je
travaille encore avec des vrais cuivre
doré vrai studio et comme les royalistes
étaient pas une musique simple à faire
ouais
bon alors vous avez déclaré j'irai voter
pour rocco siffredi quitte à se faire
enfiler autant que ce soit par un
professionnel
merci je dis ça tous les soirs sur scène
et ça leur plaît bon bah ouais ouais
parce que je suis tous les soirs dans
les spectacles au plus près des gens
c'est chaud voulez déclarer on a affaire
en face de nous a des gens mal
intentionnés
malveillants surtout dans les couches
supérieures de ce pays il ne faut pas
devenir comme eux ces gens là sont le
diable ouais ouais
avec un truc comme ça vous auriez pu
devenir président des états unis je veux
pas d'un couple de chiens
surtout basse et moi je suis dans la
bienveillance ouais c'est vrai qu'à tout
un tas de gens extrêmement malveillants
avec sami malveillants non je sais pas
quand on dit les élites c'est très
difficile à déterminer on en fait partie
déjà nous on parle trop les meilleurs
non non nous tous nous tous - le premier
tout ce qu'on dit là nous on est de
cette génération où on n'acceptait pas
qu'on me dise quoi penser quoi il ya
plein de gens qui commencent à
comprendre qu'il peut penser par
eux-mêmes voilà
pensez vous que le peuple est toujours
raison non la marine le pen a dit c'est
intéressant ça le peuple a toujours
raison même quand il a tort car sinon
qui a raison pour lui l'oligarchie non
merci ça c'est la vie noir il ne l'a pas
toujours alors cohn bendit a dit si le
peuple veut la peine de mort je suis
contre le peuple
si le peuple vote hitler je suis contre
le peuple non le peuple n'a pas toujours
raison mais j'aimerais que dans le temps
d'antenne qu'on a dans les médias on
donne un peu plus de place justement à
des gens qui parlent de valeurs qui font
du bien tu vois ses talents
voilà la bienveillance regard sur l'eau
c'est pas une ébauche c'est pas de
droite
les attentats ok il faut être
impitoyable avec avec les voyous qui
font ça mais en même temps si tu remets
pas de la culture et si tu remets pas de
l'éducation au départ tu t'en sortiras
jamais on pas laisser tomber les gens et
après des roms et vous êtes des méchants
dont faut s'occuper de départ et moi je
suis le grand blond bof de province qui
vous dis il faut faire passer ça voilà
[Musique]
m
alors j'arrive vous est ce qu'on appelle
un bon client envoie dans de nombreuses
émissions de télévision
est une sorte d'expert du petit écran on
avait trouvé comment l'interview de
sébastien la baisse était très jolie
cette suite de mots avec de la valeur
humaine samassa m'a ébranlée
[Applaudissements]
on se retrouve après la bulle a tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avançons le terrien rebond soirée
terrienne nous sommes de retour sur
terre toujours en compagnie de patrick
sébastien
leïla bekhti
et alors 28 et maintenant pas à notre
grande invitée d'honneur de la semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce un bon soir
dix mille objets au compteur une idée
toutes les 30 secondes un nouveau projet
toutes les 48 heures et donc en moyenne
nous n'avions par jour pour vous rendre
aux quatre coins du monde phillips à
vous êtes devenu l'une des marques les
plus connues de la planète merci d'être
là va être à
quatre ans l'oms est fidèle vous êtes
fidèle à votre ami de quarante ans
1976 le journal façade il y avait trois
personnes nées en 49 il y avait philippe
starck jean baptiste mondino thierry
ardisson il y en a deux qui sont devenus
des stars mondiales et inquiète toujours
là
[Musique]
dans ce film ça vous êtes cynique le
plus grand créateur contemporain vous
avez réussi à tour dessinée se vouent
hélas j'aimerais bien alors dernière
fois qu'il est venu c'est dans salut les
terriens il ya huit ans et on va voir
pour commencer ce que vous avez fait
depuis 2008 donc ses hôtels mama shelter
au début il y en avait un à paris et
puis maintenant il y en a à paris à lyon
à bordeaux à marseille à los angeles il
va y en avoir 50 en 2020 c'est quoi le
concept pourquoi ça marche non à celle
tasser avant tout le respect c'est à
dire que c'est un endroit où on respecte
les gens qui eux aussi ne peuvent mettre
que 100 euros la nuit parce qu'on est
dans une société où on respecte beaucoup
ce qu'ils peuvent mettre 1000 euros la
nuit oui tandis que là on dit que c'est
pas forcément des cons alors ça c'était
2008 2010 l'hôtel royal monceau ça c'est
pour ceux à 10000 la nuit ouais c'est ça
ils sont vraiment été un peu ordinaire
c'est la nuit vous avait démoli l'hôtel
ouais j'y étais tu étais ouais c'était
dangereux mais il ya un début décembre
un incendie il y aurait pu y avoir 50
malawi ah oui on est passé très près
pour être la cata cette année là en 2010
vous avez fait une box qui très célèbres
dont je peux pas dire le nom
clé parfaite pendant l aile dure en tout
cas il ya eu aussi le photomaton du
métro parce qu'il fait toi c'est vous
qui avait dessiné le photomaton du métro
ouais redessiné c'est pas très compliqué
je suis fan et du net voilà mais à lille
a fait que d'être géniaux alors en 2011
à une poubelle range qui s'appelle élise
pour collecter les papiers usagés dans
les entreprises et c'est surtout pour
réintégrer des gens qui en avaient bien
besoin donc c'est win win win c'est à
dire qu'on range son papier on recycle
le papier il ya des gens qui retournent
pas en taule ça compte pas mal ça
alors nous refuser de travailler pour
des marques d'alcool de tabac de pétrole
vie j'ai travaillé pour les églises des
religions mais une charte éthique un oui
et c'était fait étrangement il n'est pas
content mais pas beaucoup de ça puisque
ma compagnie doit voir près de 40 ans à
40 ans le moto était fiq le moustique on
se parle trouve le traité et on l'a
suivi et je peux vous dire c'est un gros
budget tout l'argent qu'on perd après ça
en 2012 effet le pass navigo oui bah
c'est pour anoblir le moyen de
locomotion réel de millions de gens et
d'en décider d'en faire un objet de luxe
eu ce petit bout de plastoc était
luxueux vous avez fait la voiture
électrique volt et ys oui bon c'est une
voiture électrique travail mais harry un
peu ça ressemble juste au minimum que
devrait être en permanence l'automobile
l'automobile est un véhicule qui sert
peu qui devrait beaucoup me servir mais
qui est entourée d'une énorme coquille
de merde simplement pour promener les
goths la prétention l'agressivité le
machisme là on a tout enlevé il reste
quatre sièges 4 ou et ça marche aussi
bien
le casque site pour parrot zikmu parrot
est un très bel exemple
du de la french touch en électronique
avec ce génial henri seydoux et sa
compagnie ou là il ya vraiment de
l'intelligence artificielle
ccc où on est au début du bio nisme
c'est à dire que quand un objet et qui
est encore un peu à l'extérieur de vous
mais les rapports avec à passe de
caresses comme ça je monte le son je
change de disque va et vient comme ça
c'est inouï on est dans le début de
l'harmonie entre le corps est l'objet
vous avez fait venus le lieu de steve
jobs alors là vous alliez un week-end
par mois à palo alto à l'époque où steve
jobs était malade ouais franchement
mourant même mais franchement mort en
sept ans sept ans de travail avec un
monstre est aussi l'intelligence
problème ensuite avec les héritiers
de steve jobs qui voulaient pas payer
j'ai demandé là c'est incroyable on vit
avec une famille pendant sept ans on est
de la famille papa mort
le bateau est finie on envoie la
dernière facture et on la voit jamais et
là on fait avec qui j'ai vécu pendant
sept ans et la réponse c'est des
américains
en 2014 j'ai eu la maison passe donc été
préfabriquées 100% écolo avait toujours
dit moi je me souviens des l'époque j'y
les gens vivent dans des grottes en fait
mais les appartements cédés grotte 1
publié faire autre chose bah ça c'est un
thème la maison des 3 suisses devraient
d'ailleurs un succès formidable non ça
c'est un essaie vraiment de mai
industrialisés écologique qui produisent
plus d'énergie qu'elle n'en consomme ça
m'est venu le jour où j'avais besoin de
maisons de campagne parce que mes
enfants s'accumulaient il me suis tu
n'es pas l'acheter une jolie maison à
montfort l'amaury si mes enfants non
puits de pétrole pour la chauffer donc
il faut que ce que je lègue maintenant
soient autofinancés par l'énergie
renouvelable et voilà
alors j'ai fait des tongs avec toi ben
oui bien sûr parce que je voulais
toujours faire des chaussures ça
manquait ma panoplie est donc comme mon
voyage hélas beaucoup avec ma petite
femme c'est perçu comme que la chaussure
le plus porté dans le monde c'était la
tong en 2016 et fait encore un yacht le
white pearl ouais bah ça c'est le plus
grand voilier de l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est un voilier gigantesque
la librairie est grande comme studio sur
trois étages corps c'est le plus grand
musée d'art moderne flottant du monde et
c'est surtout le plus grand laboratoire
de recherche jamais fait sur les
technologies nouvelles pour la marine
c'est un truc est très impressionnant
c'est une sorte de monstre marin
incroyable mais de là va sortir des des
milliers des milliers des milliers
d'applications pour de plus petits
bateaux la tête et paient
[Applaudissements]
et alors une prostate chez
ba c'est pas mal ya plein de gens qui en
meurent parce qu'ils comprennent pas qu
à un moment ils ont un petit peu mal là
et ce mal là-bas et ça leur donne à peu
près deux mois devant eux ouais donc on
a fait un gros machin gonflable pour
sensibiliser pour expliquer aux gens ce
que comment elle a enchaîné une procès
est aujourd'hui donc à une collection de
parfums donc c'est tout premier parfum
alors évidemment c'est pas seulement le
le contenant c'est un vrai parfum que
j'ai fait un emballage j'ai fait non non
c'est surtout le juge ça savez c'est une
histoire je voulais raconter ça prend
que deux heures mais avant quand une
dame divorce est dans la bourgeoisie
française les parents devaient l'occupé
et donc les paroles ma mère lui avait
acheté une parfumerie ma femme ma femme
ma femme est très belle oui mais ma mère
aussi était très très très très belle et
elle n'avait pas que ça à [ __ ] de
tenir une boutique et donc moi je n'ai
pas que ça à [ __ ] d'aller à l'école
donc j'étais le vendeur de la boutique
mais c'était un trou perdu et personne
et donc j'ai pris l'habitude tout petit
j'avais 7 8 ans d'aller dans la réserve
derrière de monter sur les étagères de
rester prostré sur l'étagère des heures
et des heures
totalement défoncée par toutes les
étapes
alcool les odeurs des parfums des
shampoings et c'est là où j'ai compris
ce qu'est un territoire mental c'est là
où j'ai compris que quand on est
vraiment dans la détresse absolue la
seule possibilité c'est de rêver c'est
de créer et là on a fait cette
collection est là encore quatre en a
discuté on n'a jamais parlé de faut que
ça sente laurent le fauga sont des
choses comme ça on parlait de
qu'elle serait l'odeur du vide ah ouais
qu'elle serait l'odeur de la vitesse
qu'elle serait l'odeur du temps il a la
bonne bo un
même pas toujours à jeun et cette année
en plus du parfum vous avez redessiné un
smartphone alors c'est extraordinaire
parce que l'écran recouvre toute l'
entière de la surface du smartphone
c'est surtout intéressant parce que là
on est à la fin du design il y à un bloc
de céramique noire massif il ya plus de
trouillas plus de boutons il ya qu un
écran basta cosi et la galère pour le
designer c'est alors monsieur stark les
prochains ils sont comment oui comment
quand je remets des dorures
et là on est vraiment dans la fin de
quelque chose c'est à dire que le design
abouti intelligent honnête visionnaire
et on peut plus faire moins pour
certains produits c'est extraordinaire
mais on a besoin à la fin de la matière
nous sommes enfin passer dans la
dématérialisation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très heureux d'être votre ami e c'est
très réciproque à l'aide de petites
tailles
alors philippe lui était le 18 janvier
1949 non ça c'est pas franchement je
suis même 6 mais c'est pas vrai non plus
alors votre maire était une fille à papa
très joli et votre père est un
constructeur d'avions il a fait le
premier avion de tourisme lancée après
la guerre qui s'appelait le starck as 20
c'était un inventeur toute affaire il
avait inventé les revêtements de bateaux
antidérapant le rouge à lèvres le tube
de rouge à lèvres s'enroulant this way
on est content que je serai riche
maintenant mais c'est quand même un
homme qui avait construit son premier
avion à 12 ans ah ouais quand même alors
ce qui est extraordinaire chez vous
c'est que vous passez les premières
années de votre vie sous la table de
dessin de votre père il jeter ses
feuilles vous étiez sous bureau comme ça
et vous voyez ce qu'il faisait et un
jour j'allais chez vous et j'ai vu des
feuilles de calques qui étaient épinglés
sur des films ils ont comme ça et sur
ses feuilles de calques il y avait des
courbes dessinées au crayon je vous ai
dit mais c'est pourquoi à ses courbes je
sais pas encore c'est des courbes vrai
je regardais jaillette comprendre le sa
part est prétentieux mais le signifiant
de ses courbes la dynamique pourquoi le
cx ce qui est donc le rapport
d'aérodynamique exprimer la dynamique et
après j'en ai sorti beaucoup d'objets et
votre père disparaîtra très vite de
votre vie mais ils vous laissent quand
même en héritage l'habitude et le devoir
de créer quand même oui oui j'ai appris
avec lui que pour qu'un avion vole il
faut le créer bon éviter qu'ils se
cassent la gueule il faut être rigoureux
voilà et donc c'est les deux lignes et
après je suis devenu un petit peu
autiste je suis resté gt rien je passe
je fuyais j'allais pas l'école j'étais
vraiment vraiment au fond du trou
vraiment vraiment ailleurs ma mauvaise
ailleurs et avant de me jeter par la
fenêtre je me suis dit que finalement
c'était peut-être un petit peu idiot il
fallait que j'arrive à à jarry vrai que
j'arrive à exister que je comprenne la
société que j'avais pas con oui parce
que je comprenais pas l'école et je me
suis pas la seule chose que je sais
faire finalement c'est créer à l'âge de
16 ans c'est sur les conseils d'un
amende de votre mère il vous trouve
efféminé le mec est il du bon comme il
est efféminé on va en faire un
décorateur c'est jacqueline comme son
fils va être peu d autant qu il soit
décorateur
ab3 feurs ils ont essayé alors les
destinations là vous envoyer à l'école
nissim de camondo donc vous avez appris
n'ont pas grand chose non j'avais avant
simplement là j'ai appris qu'il y avait
d'autres gens sur terre voilà oui et
d'écrire ça vous a un peu spécialisés
voir le problème avec les filles si vous
étiez totalement invisible c'était
mignon j'étais bien élevé j'étais bien
habillé j'avais une voiture de sport
rien c'est comme ça n'était pas alors ce
qui est marrant d'ailleurs c'est qu'à
l'époque pour exister comme l'homme
invisible ces thèmes et les bandelettes
bouchra bel arbre de noël n'est pas un
arbre de noël tant qu'il n'a pas les
boules et les guirlandes là vous vous
dites je vais faire des trucs pour
exister c'est ce que j'ai fait alors que
j'existais tellement peu junte était
dans une telle panique telle détresse
que c'est comme les dessins animés vous
savez y aller le type qui se noie y est
il va vers le bas et il continue il n'a
pas livoye pas qu'il est hors de l'eau
qu'il dansait bien manger et ce
exactement c'est là où je suis
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
c'était dur pour vous on se moque êtes
vous quand même et sauvage s'était fait
l'avocat le curé la gonzesse c'est quand
on est quand on est totalement
à sociale mais sans le savoir sans être
un rebelle j'étais super gentil
superpole et je n'avais pas du tout du
tout les codes servant
aujourd'hui vous êtes pays riches et
célèbres vous êtes assez riche pour ne
pas savoir combien vous gagnez
c'est peut-être une des seules raisons
de gagner de l'argent ouais c'est pas
avoir à calculer en fait vous rêvasser
je suis un rêveur professionnels
rêvasser toute la journée après de votre
femme c'est très important à fabrication
les modules afin d'occuper 90% de mon
cerveau avait nommé je ne pourrais pas
areva c'est tout le temps je ne pourrais
pas totalement en dehors de la plaque je
pourrais pas totalement une boule de
cristal s'il n'y avait pas ma femme qui
avait un petit cordon ombilical et qui
me permettait quand même d'arriver
encore un communiqué sans ça je serai
totalement autiste au canada trou mais
je suis je suis je suis un moine mois
vous rêvez assez dans une douzaine de
maisons ou quand même oui mais ça c'est
professionnel parce que j'ai besoin de
voir la mer je voudrais voir la forêt
les dunes géantes en fonction par
exemple si on vous confie un boulot vous
dites je vais aller dans cette maison de
campagne et que là je vais trouver
l'idée à cette annonce et pas trouvé
l'idée si le niveau de concentration
c'est à dire que j'ai des maisons où il
ya des amis donc vous êtes un petit peu
distrait ya des maisons il n'y a plus
d'amis il ya des voisins à qui je veux
dire bonjour ayant des maisons n'y a
plus rien du tout ouais et donc suivant
le niveau de complications je vais au
plus loin possible où on reste un mois
deux mois sans sans parler sans rien
dire sans eau sans électricité
oui mais on est très content
[Musique]
alors vous aviez déclaré vouloir arrêter
à l'âge de 50 ans c'est raté
c'est raté pour plusieurs raisons c'est
que
il y a eu ce président américain bush
qui a mis le feu à la terre c'est à dire
qu'on commençait à un petit morceau de
civilisation civilisé quand ce criminel
de guerre a mis le feu et il a fallu
tout revoir à ce moment les des
problèmes sont arrivés les nouvelles
nécessités il a fallu continuer tout a
été chamboulé et on y est encore on
arrive toujours pour éteindre le feu on
n'arrive toujours pas à répondre aux
questions donc on y est toujours et je
pense qu'on en a encore pour un bon
paquet de temps que l'on a vu les
dernières nouvelles oui il est inquiet
comment ne pas l'être à ce que je
connais bien je connais c'est vraiment
c'est pire que ce qu'on dit le gros
problème c'est que
il a jamais voulu être élu il voulait
faire une énorme opération de pub le
problème c'est qu'il ne sait plus quoi
faire il est assez intelligent pour
comprendre qu'il ne peut pas faire ce
qu'il a dit et il est dans une panique
totale et quand les gens me disent
qu'est ce qu'il va faire limite ne le
sait pas lui mais il ne le sait pas le
mec j'aimerai pas être le matin dans
l'île doit transmettre en disant mais
bordel qu'est ce que je vais faire c'est
incroyable
phil hughes merci on vous laisse pas
partir seul un avion résultats' unis
voilà et nous on continue avec le black
days chanteur humoriste m
[Musique]
je veux l'interprète l'interprète
l'interprète musique
d'avant échappé d'un rocher bien
c'est bien
en fait c'est tout ce mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu auras besoin
les inconnus ouais
[Musique]
facile et notre
attention belgique
[Musique]
est malade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben
ali
2 allah
attention music in
maschera
[Musique]
c'est très bizarre pourquoi ils sont
rappelés le palm la chance dans leur
demande ils ricanent
sam hd lyonnais voit toujours intrigué
mais bon ils sont drôles musique
la gare
[Musique]
au pub à l'époque ses cartons musique
mais il est jeune
john f
on a dit en même temps sa jeunesse ouais
bah oui c'est normal a commencé à la
classe on donne le point palmade alors
c'est un petit peu normal on me majda
les musiques
[Musique]
musique
malgré l'été
oh
j'aime bien max boublil faire un
spectacle ensemble je sais on sait que
j'adore mois en 16 surkiffe logique
[Applaudissements]
elie kakou
[Musique]
lee
pour sébastien aussi musique
à part si mes films et lui mais palop
alors
[Musique]
c'est génial tu vas mal par la
crise bon je suis là facile musique
[Applaudissements]
tu sais
mais comment
c'était en 2000 alors déjà 10 à 16 ans
ouais il est toujours dans la tête
musique
f0 que je savais faire
[Musique]
l usure de jean michel jarre quand même
ce n'est que pour ça que j'ai dit oui
s'est retrouvé en studio avec jean
michel jarre ouais j'ai pas vérifié les
paroles avant de chanter mais
je m'en fous de musique fait mon kiff
c'est patrick sébastien
qui a gagné sur la pièce
raconter une histoire c'est bien
[Musique]
voilà c'était la peur de ces luttes et
on se retrouve après la bulle a tout
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leur romance on était alors à vos
soirées terriens sommes de retour sur
terre toujours en compagnie de patrick
sébastien
de pierre balmain de
leïla bekhti
jarry
et de leur fille
et on passe maintenant à notre thé au
top de la semaine
[Musique]
les labels tir bonsoir
alors vous tenez le rôle principal de la
nouvelle création originale de canal
jour polaire très bon démarrage lundi
dernier avec 850 1000 pour la première
et combien pour la deuxième je prends un
peu plus de 900 milles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le pitch à kiruna petite bourgade
deux suédoises un citoyen français
retrouvé ligoté à l'hélice d'un
hélicoptère est décapité
ça n'a aucun ni tête
alors vous êtes policière parisienne
envoyés sur les lieux du crime au coeur
de l'été arctique pour aider la police
locale là bas vous mener l enquête aux
côtés du procureur suédois qui ne se
doute pas du doubs leur passé que vous
tentez de fuir vénat
oui oui c'est toute l'histoire c'est
très bien fait moi j'ai regardé je te
gère mais tu nous d'où le thème dans c
crois vraiment c'est incroyable la suède
est devenue d'ailleurs depuis quelques
années le pays des free l'heure il écrit
et on y tient des histoires de
serial-killer de massacre en même temps
ils sont tellement chic et qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent faire d'autre que tuer
des gens ce qu'ils valent menthe et les
et le suspense est vraiment une
spécialité suédoise d désormais c'est
vrai que quand tu montes une armoire
ikea tu te demandes toujours si tu vas y
arriver avant la fin de la journée
et voilà donc quatre mois en laponie
sans frédéric lopez lui c'est assez joli
c'était c'est joli le plus dur c'était
quoi c'était le froid le jour s'ennuie
ou les chansons d'abba
répondait là
ça a été très dur ouais c'est un espèce
de jour sans fin c'était s'y fait jamais
nuit tombée ce qu
avec en sus des eskimos
travers ma fille ouais je dormais quatre
heures par nuit c'était j'ai réellement
perdu tous mes repères et et en même
temps je bénis ces moments parce que ça
a complètement nourri mon personnage
ouais donc
sur mac et des moustiques là bas les
moustiques comme ça je saurai non
et en plus en plus choisir cette heure
d'anglais par jour exactement s'est
arrêtée un français
vous avez dit il est là il y aura un
avant et un après quand même ça a été
une expérience extrêmement de l'eau je
parle humainement je sais que vraiment
je me sens je me sens profondément
changé de s'endurcir quoi je prends
pineda transport dans les choses les
parties chaudes est revenu très vite
[Musique]
la
victime a
hier encore un phoque regarde
les la mema avait des coups de cafard
c'est vrai
et comme tout les gonzesses quand elle a
des coups de cafard et qu'elle pleure l
écoute de la musique triste histoire de
faire encore plus mal c'est pas très
exactement comme il est passé une sale
période non non non c'était c'était une
expérience formidable et puis j'ai
côtoyé des loups j'ai côtoyé des rennes
j'ai fait de nico j'ai vu des des
paysages extraordinaires fin c'était
c'était une aurore boréale
ouais ça c'est qu'il y ait la chance de
voir une on regarde à cause ensemble
[Musique]
celui que tu cherches
est invisible
comme une crevasse étroite on ne la voit
qu'au dernier moment
[Musique]
et
j'essaie d'appréhender un meurtrier qui
cherche à causer du tort à toute la
communauté samy
on peut tuer pour violation propriété
zee non non bien sûr que non longtemps
vacants sinon je suis ici pour le boulot
fait quoi je sers la france 2 comme vous
[Musique]
oh
bravo voilà les petits dons géo polaire
gros succès pour le démarrage sur canal
lundi dernier sur tous les lundis aller
là nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la
première fois sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle il ya onze ans pour
sheitan zut il venu avec vincent cassel
ensuite il ya eu un prophète qui vous a
permis de remporter un mari les tout ce
qui brille qui vous a permis de
remporter un césar c'est très bien on
regarde ce césar je vous trouve
formidable dans cette séquence tu césar
quand j'ai su que j'étais nommé j'ai
appelé mes parents pour leur demander
s'ils avaient payé tous les votants
tellement je n'arrivais pas à y croire
je voudrais remercier géraldine nakache
et hervé mimran vos yeux m'ont rendu
plein et je suis je suis tellement fière
de vous avoir rencontré je vais un peu
dire n'importe quoi parce que je suis
trop ému je veux remercier audrey lamy
nader manu payet à tous les comédiens du
film partagez ce césar avec les quatre
autres comédiennes qui était nommé
dans la catégorie
remets ma mère
et ma soeur d'avoir rendu ma vie plus
belle plus douce plus tout et je vais
finir par remercier mon prince charmant
qui m'a
avant toi il n'y avait rien mon coeur je
t'aime merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai elle était déjà transis de
froid les peurs
c'est vrai c'est vrai bien était chez
elle en nuisette on lui dit tu l'as du
j'arrive
[Rires]
ne touchez pas
même si
je sais que je dois sauter
les relais
[Musique]
vous reconnaissez la wii la grèce est
heureusement
tu sais qu'au début je pense que c'est
une chanson de claude françois et un
jour vers au sens on est dans la salle
de bain et je suis en train de faire
et elle me dit mais qu'est ce qui change
suivi de jean claude françois et éviter
qu'on attend de moi et la bombe ne
divorcent
les jurés pensé que
cet album
alors vous toujours à lui avec géraldine
nakache
temps vous faites pas la suite de new
york tout va bien à new york c'est un
pitch est incroyable c'est géraldine
nakache qui se fait payer des vacances à
new york par un producteur de cinéma et
qui filme ses potes qui vient de passer
le le week end qu vrai nom mais vous
vous en voulez à géraldine nous à nous
avoir entraîné dans new york jamais je
voudrais jamais elle prépare son
prochain film qu'on va tourner lalanne
et royal est alors c'était bien tout ce
qui brille dans tout ce qui brille ce
génial franchement c'est génial je jure
et new york c'est bien de thé pas lourd
de dire quinze fois que c'était une
merde c'est bien c'est tout en
délicatesse d'antan est-ce que tu as
pensé de new york
il ya un truc que j'adore chez nous
c'est quand vous êtes dans un hôtel vous
ne supportez pas que la femme de chambre
face votre lit tous à charbon si dsk
avait fait la même chose je serai
président de la république donc c'est
vrai mais je supportais pas non puisque
de toute façon je supporterai pas de
voir qui que ce soit faire quelque chose
et être un côté être assis derrière je
vais vous aider la femme de chambre à
faire votre lit en effet toutes les
chambres
lorsqu'on va faire maintenant vous êtes
une vraie actrice on va voir on va faire
une interview fait ou à faire
[Musique]
gagnez un césar vous fait signe à un
contrat avec l'oréal oui
avoir une liaison avec nicolas bedos
tafer encore non je suis marié il chante
faux liens
soutenir des sans papiers
aux toilettes encore plus dur
quand il est au top à elle seule un
joueur visé
j'ai pas encore c'est que c'est un
papillon
le fait
qu'on
me dise apport d'au moins clair un film
à plus de 5 millions d'entrées n'ont pas
encore
refusé de parler de votre vie privée a
fait déjà je veux pas parler de votre
vie privée mais moi j'ai rencontré votre
mari par heim le jour le jour la
diffusion du prophète à calme je
traverse toute la ville pour aller le
voir pour le féliciter et quand j'arrive
devant lui et bien tu es venu qu'est-ce
que je suis content que tu sois là j'ai
trouvé ça génial d'une humilité total
alors que toute la ville le vénéraient
surtout avec la qualité du film ouais
coucher avec son partenaire sur un film
jamais se sera jamais fait jamais c'est
quand j'avais un scénar
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors j'arrive jeu long métrage vu comme
ça sur tous les invités qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la bekhti c'est vrai que
mon expertise est importante pour les
gens
elle est parfaite ah bon et j'espère
vraiment pour l'avoir il est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
alors vous préférez les comédies où les
drames a priori faire lille 2-2 ouais
prenez votre temps est drôle c'est pas
maman
mon frère on le sait qu une fonte plus
beaux rôles ce serai maman et j'adore
mon métier aussi mais je suis perdue
quand je parle de ça
[Musique]
on passe maintenant un autre tu es qui
toi de la semaine
[Musique]
j'arrive à mon soir
alors jarry vous est ce que l'on appelle
at est donc un bon client on vous a vu
chez arthur vos passages dans le star
sous hypnose son culte vous dites
d'ailleurs cette émission a changé ma
vie c'est vrai que messmer vous a fait
tomber amoureux de lara fabian
vous avez déclaré ça serait une bonne
mère pour mes enfants lara fabian les
forces messmer on a franchement j'y
croyais pas quand on m'a proposé
l'émission j'ai dit moi à tout ce qui
est voyant et tout ça je vois pas où est
vraiment gym a pris totalement je suis
rentré dans le jeu est vraiment j'ai eu
des sentiments pour leur famille pendant
un mois il a dû revenir pour vous
désavouer impliqué ouais tu y croies
patrick hassane mossi faux pas qui
s'approche de moi donc là je n'aime pas
cette guinness père ils pourraient me
faire arrêter de fumer du roi année
c'est sûr qu'ils joignent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui j'ai lu j'ai lu les canaux
katp et tu met du temps à atterrir quand
même chez environ 10 personnes dans ma
tête lara fabian malik père jonathan est
un cas n'est pas joli mais voulant pas
bien pour toi pas écouté la ces comme
palmade véronique sanson sais mais c'est
connu des femmes je suis curieux j'ai
pas voulu je rappelle que la famille ne
compte pas
[Rires]
bon alors on vous a vu donc chez arthur
dans vendredi tout est permis chez
stéphane bern donc comment ça va bien il
a alors votre texte et est relu par le
comptable exactement ouais j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi ils avaient tellement
peur de ce que je pouvais faire il
n'était pas drôle et à chacun faisait ça
tu peux pas ça passera par là et du coup
au bout d'un moment je lui ai dit
d'aller se faire [ __ ] passoire et ça
me saoulait et les tons chair qui
étaient là comptent exactement non mais
je leur donnais pas les mon texte en
fait à jordy regarde c'est ça ça te
plaît c'est gentil et tout ça et après
je jouais n'importe quoi en plateau et
on ne couper au montage ils ont été des
missions au final alors vous avez dans
le grand music quiz dans l'académie des
neuf dans mot de passe dans touche pas à
mon poste dans le plus grand cabaret du
monde donc face à la bande notre action
ou vérité dans la toux la poule il ya
que le jour du seigneur je vais pas fait
retard pourtant j'étais en fin de quart
trois ans je me suis fait virer de
l'église parce que je chantais etienne
etienne sur l'hôtel
s'est pas passé
il est là maintenant consolidée rien on
en profite pour vous dire que vous avez
un vrai métier et vous saurez donc sur
la scène de bobino avec votre spectacle
atypique à partir du 19 décembre plus
tourner + dvd oui bah en fait c'est tout
le temps spectacle quand vous êtes tout
seul mais moi je m'ennuie jamais parce
que sa mère est ce que depuis que je
suis tout petit j'ai toujours été seul
donc je me suis inventé des trucs voilà
là normalement ma fille tu es censé me
défoncer après l'émission
[Rires]
non mais moi j'avais trois frères qui
était très différent de moi qui tu es
passionné par le foot la chasse et tout
mais moi j'étais dans ma chambre et je
jouais sissi l'impératrice avec ma
couette et je m'entraînais à mourir
devant la glace donc c'était dans ma
tête il y avait que moi je fais le pitch
du spectacle donc fait la queue au pôle
emploi retire pas l'emploi rapporté
différentes expériences professionnelles
policiers majorettes caissier prêtre est
d'ailleurs la vanne qui tue donc le
prêtre lui dire mettez-vous à genoux et
lui lui dit vous n'avez pas compris
d'abord ça j'adore cette vanne elle est
indépassable et pourtant je catholique
voyait mais celles gérées à lourdes et
c'est pas du tout
alors atypique c'est à la fois du
stand-up du chant de la danse du mime
enfin peut-être votre numéro quoi ouais
hein mais parce que c'est un mot qu'on a
toujours utilisé en parlant de moi et
les voisins des brahmanes à enghien il
pas comme ces files atypique il ya un
truc très heureux qui s'est passé un
soir vous avez vu une femme voilée qui
était au deuxième rang et évolue vite
excusé moi madame si vous posez la
question que tout le monde se pose est
ce que vous savez une ceinture
d'explosifs
j'adore bas parce que je pense qu'on
peut rire de tout bienvenue voilà qui ne
rira pas mort à exactement on regarde à
cause ensemble
[Musique]
bonjour madame enchanté jarry police
nationale solide à plein fouet
inquiète
c'est rigolo comme prénom
ça va être long
votre fils a disparu et folie
on peut rigoler
mais ça va attention je vous comprends
que je fermais que les dix fois par jour
sauf que moi j'ai un double
à partir de maintenant je vais vous
demander de répondre à tout mais qui
est ce que son prénom commence par un
peu comme sophie
non
[Applaudissements]
maintenant on va parler de vous
vous venez de rappeler sur lyon
et dont j'ai un tout petit village de
600 habitants voilà vous êtes nés
prématurément ouais le 5 août 1977 suite
à un accident de voiture ouais ma mère
est sorti de la voiture et le mec en
face le dit étoiles grosse vache ouais
et là je me suis vénère à l'intérieur
les voilà si l'essm a passé et voilà et
vous êtes nous alors familles qui ont
rien à voir avec le spectacle dans le
côté cédé fondeur ouais de l'autre côté
c'est des viticulteurs voilà ambiance
plutôt chasse pêche tradition je suis
vraiment très bien ouais on est des
bonnes âmes quoi ouais ouais ouais
j'ai tellement différent de votre
famille que que vous demandez s'il
n'avait pas été échangé à distance mais
moi j'ai même fait des recherches ouais
j'ai pensé pendant des années que
j'avais été adoptée puisque je me disais
c'est pas possible
ouais il ya un truc à un moment donné
ouais qui fait que pendant que mes
frères vont à la chasse mais je vais
vendre des oeufs sur le marché pour
m'acheter une barbe il ya un truc mais
des files et franchement tu échoues
moi je ne savais pas ce qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur ça pas lâcher
pas toujours alors j'imagine que vous
n'avez jamais eu affaire de coming out
quand vous avez approché vos parents
vous ont dit oui on sait and on and on
passe quand plus mon père disait tout le
temps à table si un jour j'ai un de mes
fils pdg mais une cartouche ouais comme
quoi il était guère friands
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai régulièrement fait l'amour à
des femmes j'étais pas convaincu par le
projet mais je me suis entêtée jusqu'à
24 ans est à 24 ans j'ai couché avec le
frère de la femme que je devais épouser
amélie est vrai je rejetais un gag ah
non c'est vraiment vrai elle me dit on
devait se marier une semaine après il me
dit à mon frère qu'est légionnaires qui
peut venir à nos fiançailles j bay
county n'a qu'à rester dormir à la
maison je me lève à 3h du matin pour
faire pipi et bim
vous dit j'en suis fier parce que si la
vie un choisi ça pour moi c'est qu'il ya
un sens à tout ça ouais parce que je
crois que c'est tellement difficile
aujourd'hui d'être heureux d'être soi
voilà moi c'est pas sûr que j'ai fait je
suis né comme ça j'en suis vraiment fier
même si voilà on charrie puis bon c'est
vrai que c'était très efféminé quand
même mais j'aime ce défaut comment ta
paire de seins
non mais moi je suis fier parce que je
pense qu'on vit qu'une fois autant vivre
à fond et puis dès qu'on est bien qu'ils
aillent se faire
il ya des gens qui s'en aperçoivent pas
voilà les voyelles des fois je me fais
draguer par des femmes je me dis mais
qu'est ce qu'elle ne voit pas
une base de votre père qui formidable
avant de mourir et vous a dit surtout
vie
mais ouais mais je suis surpris que vous
sachiez ça j'ai eu la chance ou est
d'accompagner mon papa a jusqu'à la fin
et comme c'était un homme avec qui je
m'entendais pas du tout et qui a
toujours dit quand on appelait à la
maison j'ai pas de fils qui s'appelle
jarry au les dernières minutes de sa vie
m'a dit vraiment ce mot il m'a dit vie
c'est bien là bas ça fait du bien euh je
suis né à ce moment là je pense
l'histoire sur ton père va peut-être
faire son chemin et il ya plein de terre
qui vont se dire j'ai peut-être un truc
à dire à mon fils homo avant de partir
mais ce choix
vous pourriez il ya beaucoup de deux
familles qui viennent voir mon spectacle
et qui me disent écoutez on a mis notre
enfant la rue ya trois ans et en vous
voyant aussi heureux aussi bien dans
votre peau je pense qu'on a fait une
connerie vous marier
c'est pas parce que moi perçoit la vie
en fait un peu comme un saladier de
fruits j'ai envie de goûter tous les
fruits
jours
bon train
[Musique]
à
jours
ça
alors comme j'ai demandé ce soir de
faire une petite critique après chaque
interview vous êtes trouvé comment là je
sais pas se calcule pas je suis père
impressionné parce que vraiment pierre
palmade pour moi c'est vraiment la reine
mère c'est la référence
[Applaudissements]
vraiment quand j'étais petit je voyais
dans ma télé je me disais mais je me
sens proche de ce monsieur et quand je
l'aï rencontré pour la première fois
j'étais tout tremblant oui pour d'autres
raisons
voilà j'étais la p3 d'accepter franches
en club sur terre après la vie
[Musique]
au revoir re bonsoir
l'intérieur re re re bonsoir luthériens
nous sommes enchantés toujours en
compagnie de patrick sébastien
[Applaudissements]
pierre palmade
de leïla bekhti de jarry
de laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]
évacuons mesdames messieurs c'est
l'heure de guillon à 2017
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jboss mais toujours la chine possède à
présent de poids aux élections s'il te
plaît à nos
méninges dans l'est sont beaucoup plus
grandes que nous du ces
avant de demander à élise lucet de
cesser d'importuner sarkozy avec son
reportage sur la sphère bygmalion michel
field avaient été conviés dans le plus
grand secret à prendre le thé chez les
bruni sarkozy
michel tu fais une petite et des verts
tient la mort chasse mais dans celle y
fais toi plaisir un karl acheter tous
les parfums che mariage frères tu vas
coup ça tu veux fumer la pipe fantasy
pas tu es chez toi et moi michel se
connaît bien on s'apprécie alors tu vas
dire à cette pouf liasse des dix plus et
que si elle veut garder son boulot à
france 2 en mai 2010 est son torchon sur
bygmalion ses approximations ses
mensonges l intérêt à faire des coupes
mais dû s'adapter à la main ce veilleur
parce que franchement 1 franchement ces
méthodes d'un guy zitte rice de mes
couilles elle peut se [ __ ] je pense et
je peux promettre une chose mon mimi
sexy tu arrives à calmer cette conne le
poste de delphine ernotte la présidence
de france télévisions il est pour toi
j'ai besoin de gens indépendants comme
toi et quand du caractère mon mimi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon ça c'est fait
tu attends de millet maintenant qu'il
est bonne intrigue est pas on à la
banque qui arrivent les autres ils sont
très bien là sont ils sont un niveau
fais moi confiance
on est loin d'être chômage
[Rires]
bernard godet vice président de la
fédération française de rugby démis de
ses fonctions pour avoir mis en place un
système de revente frauduleuse de
billets ah bah non non faut pas virer
godet gonnet il est expert comptable du
rpr et de l'ump c'est lui qu'elle gérait
la campagne de sarko en 2007 bygmalion
tout ça c'est lui quand la fédération
langage elle sait qu'en matière de
fausses factures caisses noires double
billetterie godet c'est le meilleur oh
ben non elle engage pour ses qualités
elle le vire pour les mêmes raisons
c'est dégueulasse
[Musique]
la doyenne de l'humanité emma morano a
fêté ses cent dix sept ans on est
content pour elle on la félicite
on espère juste que c'est que l que les
morano ne possède pas le gène de la
longévité
117 en a dit nenê en 63 si on doit la
supporter jusqu en 2080 ça va pas être
possible
à 2080 elle pour accompagner la
candidature de sarko à la présidentielle
de 2000 22 2027 2030 de 2037
2042 c'est pas pour moi que je me
présentais avertissons c'est pour la
france
nicolas hulot refuse de se rallier à
yannick jadot tant mieux tant mieux les
verts ils peuvent pas se blairer entre
eux c'est tout d'un coup vous en avez 2
qui s'entendent ça fait un groupe et un
groupe chez les verts ça déstabilise
tout le monde
gilbert collard plaide pour une primaire
du fn en 2022 ah ça peut être sympa une
primaire avec que des extrémistes
mesdames messieurs bonjour bienvenue à
ce premier débat de la primaire
d'extrême droite samoa huit candidats
jean marie le pen qui est un tube est en
fauteuil roulant ce sera à son infirmier
qui parlera pour lui marine le pen eric
zemmour robert ménard on espère qu'il ne
quittera pas le plateau en cours
d'émission florian philippot dieudonné
et alain soral tous vont essayer ce soir
de vous convaincre alors beaucoup de
choses vous rassemble sortie de l'europe
préférence nationale retour au franc
quelques différences sur l'homosexualité
par exemple robert ménard vous êtes
contre vous avez fait retirer des
affiches de prévention sur le sida à
béziers jean marie le pen vous vous êtes
clairement homophobe [ __ ] et rouquin avez
vous hurlé un jour si on peut essuyer un
peu monsieur le pen il régurgite merci
une chose vous rassemble là dessus on
peut parler de consensus c'est le refus
des migrants la haine de l'étranger la
france aux français pour en parler tout
de suite nos deux spécialistes maison
elisabeth lévy et patrick buisson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e.on a atteint
tu vois qu'on a encore de belles années
devant nous
international très bel hommage de la
part de jean luc mélenchon à fidel
castro messages enflammés sur twitter
rassemblement au pied de la statue de
simon bolivar fleurs et bougies fidel
castro ce sont soixante-dix mille
prisonniers politiques 630 et une
condamnation à mort torture physique et
psychique dans les geôles du régime
depuis
1959 je signale argent lui que s'il veut
vraiment se faire plaisir
le survêtement 2 fidel castro est déjà
en vente sur ebay très bon état a peu de
sens sur léman en chine mais ça devrait
partir au lavage
[Applaudissements]
carnet rose
on enchaîne avec un heureux événement
léa salamé confirme qu'elle est enceinte
c'est officiel un événement uniquement
pour moi a déclaré la journaliste à nos
confrères d'europe 1 une déclaration
tout en simplicité d'une trentaine de
lignes
oui oui je reconfirme aujourd'hui je
suis enceinte c'est un événement privé
mais j'aimerais quand même en parler
j'ai eu un rapport sexuel il ya trois
mois et demi ça s'est bien passé puis
suite à des nausées et un retard de
règles j'ai fait un test de grossesse le
matin au réveil les urines sont plus
concentrés un jet de cinq secondes sur
une tige absorbante qui a viré au bleu
depuis j'ai fait une échographie le bébé
va bien le coeur bat la longueur cranio
caudal est normal car son office je ne
sais pas je souhaite garder la surprise
en tout cas je ne mettrai pas ma
carrière professionnelle entre
parenthèses j'ai la chance d'être en
2007 et en 2007 une femme n'a pas à
choisir entre sa vie personnelle
passionnel ferrat un enfant pour soi et
pour quel rang 10 comme bret le
philosophe sereine qui ne gardent la
mère aimante apprend à son enfant à
marcher seul je pourrais aussi vous
citer dolto mais je peux rester discrète
oui je sais c'est un événement qui ne
concerne que moi
[Applaudissements]
heureusement qu'elle attend pas des
jumeaux
ou simple
[Musique]
alors que l'on a frôlé une crise
institutionnelle ce week-end entre
manuel valls et françois hollande le
premier ministre a tenu à rassurer
l'opinion sur sa fidélité au président
je suis évidemment aux fidèles qui
président à la famille nous devons nous
rassembler être unis ne pas semer la
division c'est dans ces moments qu'il
faut être fort ne pas quitter le navire
sous prétexte que le bilan de françois
nuls exécrable à chier trois millions
cinq cent mille chômeurs 6 millions de
pauvres tu dois au contraire me
sacrifier ne pas laisser françois se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
c'est ma responsabilité d'être candidat
à sa place le protéger d'une déroute une
fessée déculottée je dois l'épaule et ne
pas laisser cet homme oui et
inconsistants qui se répand auprès des
journalistes sombrer encore plus de
doigts eux endiguer sa chute restés
fidèles
[Applaudissements]
on
va écouter voilà l'exécutif s'entend à
merveille on a évidemment pleinement
rassuré à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup à vos avant c'était les flammes
d'ici
la semaine prochaine et d'ici là sur
scène à paris jusqu'à fin décembre et
maintenant on passe à votre tt ou de la
smag
tu étais où
pierre bellemare bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
pierrot tu viens puis au soir on ne voit
plus la dernière fois qu'on s'est vus
c'est en 2005 dans tout le monde en
parle c'est pour la pièce de ruquier si
c'était à refaire depuis rien pas un
coup de fil pas une visite
tu fais la gueule
j'avais dit une connerie encore non pas
du tout au contraire tu m'avais fait un
hommage à magnan et poires et mémorable
j'adore ma vie j'en suis reconnaissant
ban était l'année parce que là je
regarde la liste des gens avec qui je
suis fâché en ce moment là bon robert
ménard ou et
marc olivier fogiel on s'est réconciliés
guy bedos on s'est réconciliés joey
starr se réconcilier alessandra sublet
avec pas qu'on soit fâchés avec elle
michel drucker non pas en ce moment je
vais voir son spectacle samedi donc on
va se réconcilier
inévitablement ah si il ya le mec des
kebabs en bas de chez moi
les en effet chérie c'est sûr vous
n'êtes pas sur la liste 1 donc on n'est
pas fait maintenant je te rappeler alors
c'est vrai que ça fait onze ans qu'on
s'est pas vu mais qui a 11 ans votre vie
pierre palmade a brutalement changé
c'était le 16 août 2005 ce jour là vous
avez décidé pierre palmade que c'était
fini les soirées jusqu'à pas d'heure et
les excès en tout genre gej
j'ai eu cette phrase extraordinaire j'ai
décidé ce jour-là que je souffrais d'une
maladie on peut appeler ça l'alcoolisme
on peut appeler ça l'addiction sexuelle
mais j'ai cessé de nommer ça l'a fait
un jour vers entre 30 et 35 ans se dit
mais je crois pas je suis en train de
faire la fête je crois que suis en train
de me pourrir la vie vous avez décidé ne
pas replonger dans l'enfer d'une vie
marrante
non non j'ai compris que s'amenuisaient
alors après je dois je dois rendre des
comptes à personne mais j'ai décidé que
c'était nuisibles mais une phrase
formidable
comme je ne connais pas la tempérance
j'ai préféré l'abstinence
j ça
mais c'est vachement bien j'espère vous
l'avez jamais ce mot tempérant je
connaissais pas le moteur ne connaît pas
le mot non mais c'est beau voilà alors
après on arrête pas du jour au lendemain
on le décide mais c'est un long
processus il faut se surveiller parce
qu'il ya des eaux il ya débat il ya des
rechutes et puis voilà alors j'ai
contourné dans toute la france est au
zénith de paris les 20 21 et 22 décembre
2016 avec ils s'aiment depuis 20 ans
donc c'est un best of de la série la
série 6ème ils se sont aimés ils se re
aiment ce qui est nouveau en fait c'est
que suivant les soirs on a droit à trois
couples différents il ya la roque et
vous
l'original l'originel muriel robin et
vous ce qu'est nouveau voilà et laroque
et muriel et ce qui est très bien c'est
que france 2 donc a décidé en janvier de
diffuser muriel et la route vers le
couple lesbien tout à fait et puis ça
c'est historique d
un couple de femmes soit pas un film ou
une pièce militante c'est vraiment ça va
sur la banalisation que c'est vraiment
pour faire rire coire est tout d'un coup
ça pleut [ __ ] douce au féminin ouais
c'est ça aussi c'est par un plan à trois
c'est une tourmente de l'autre c'est
surtout une idée de michel et c'est
drôle alors moi je reste jamais juré un
jour avec muriel c'est mon dieu quel
actif de jeu avec muriel puis le genre
les gens savent qu'on est jumeaux tous
les deux donc tout à coup on arrive tous
les deux poids pour jouer le mariage
puis tous les autres scènes c'est
vraiment bien muriel et michel je sais
qu'elle kiffe ensemble oui parce qu'en
fait vous êtes extrêmement proches tous
les trois même si je tiens à le dire
jamais rien eu entre vous trois
il ya très longtemps et alors un soir et
alors j'ai arrêté de boire après
[Musique]
est ce que françois baroin est allé voir
muriel en couple oui si nous a pris à
trois mois pour l'accès des libyens pour
la création du spectacle elle a vu les
trois il est fasciné avec moi qu'il
aurait voulu faire un acteur si cela
était alors vous changer de partenaire
donc pratiquement tous les soirs c'est
comment vous protéger
ça lui rappelle votre grande époque au
fait les gens bien compris qu'un coup
muriel joue mon rôle avec michel bien
coup elle joue le rôle de michel avec
moi c'est génial qu'est une idée celle h
à laroque je ne voulais pas faire les 20
ans juste michel et moi pour avoir la
recette est là là dit il ce coup de
folie ça c'est l'arrivée on regarde à
quoi ça ressemble
il ya 20 ans isabelle et martin alias
michel et pierre se sont mariés
ils se sont unis moi j'ai envie de me
faire conduire par le plus je les
chauffeurs de la terre
alias muriel a eu envie de partager
leurs chamailleries
parce qu'il ya encore cette année chaque
fois que j'apportais les vivants
dit et atari j'en ai marre de sa mère
son peuple une madame des records elle
part à la mer à la neige à la montagne
je m'en fous mais qu'elle dégage alors
elle remonte le nil est le descend est
et ce qu'elle veut mais qu'elles me
populaire sinon je fais bouffer ça calme
ils s'aiment depuis longtemps 3 de plus
différents
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial
c'est marrant c'est fou de voir des
coupes qui s'engueulent toute la journée
payer 40 euros pour aller voir un couple
qui sont la soirée sauf que nous on
s'insulte pas on se blesse pas c'est
juste
les scoops le lay s'en sortent toujours
bien il se protège quand même
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois qu'on s'était vu
c'était pour la pièce de laurent ruquier
qui s'appelait si c'était à faire et on
va faire une interview si c'était enfin
[Musique]
si c'était à refaire avec qui évite
auriez-vous de travail est
alors la seule personne mais ça y est
c'est pardonné avec l'avion s'était pas
très bien entendu juste avec dominique
lavanant ah oui c'était mais c'est un
peu de ma faute aussi bon voilà google
s'est
fait pardonner mais si c'était un faire
quelle histoire d'amour éviteriez vous
la dernière
jouera dernière puisqu'on vient de se
séparer donc oui c'est fini pourquoi
pas mais sans rentrer dans le détail
ce qu'il a merdé ans est toujours le
dernier qu'on aime le moins comme si
c'était à refaire quelle drogue n'essaye
auriez-vous pas légaux peut-être way too
much égaux
à 20 ans c'est un peu jeune quand même
pour être un petit peu l'inconnu si ces
affaires avec qui couchent auriez-vous
directement pour réussir jamais bien
fogiel à un moment fogiel aucouturier
directement avec fogiel bah oui c'est
lui qui a pas voulu
[Applaudissements]
si c'était en fait quel truc sexuelle et
ses yeux riez vous beaucoup plus tôt le
poney
je sais pas moi
si c'était à faire quelle connerie
essayez vous de ne pas faire
merde je les aime bien mais connerie
parce que je m'en suis sorti indemne au
calme on appris des choses on va mettre
toutes mes conneries
mais vous êtes drôle ça il fallait me le
dire à l'époque pendant dix ans je dois
clavier pied non non non non non je vais
pas me dire ah non c'est pas lui dire
moi je suis garante exactement lui
arrive bien que sa coiffure comme ça et
tout le monde faisait bon nom n'osez pas
vous le dire c'est voilà une fois mayor
je me souviens j'étais comme ça au bord
de la piscine avec m eh ben elle me
regarde et je plonge la piscine et donc
je sors de la piscine comme ça elle me
fait appel à voilà
si c'était à refaire est-ce que vous
épouser leur y ait un nouveau verrou
nexans
je n'en ferai pas vu vu toutes les
moqueries que ça a mené on aurait dû je
resterai discret si je rencontrais
verront peut-être qu'il a avec marie
myriam en ce moment mais il est discret
quoi mais voilà la baisse comme un
oiseau
sébastien il a dit pincement au coeur
patrick sébastien bach et myriam patrick
40 ans il ya 40 ans quand en oiseau
l'enfant 40 ans 77 allait gagner
l'eurovision du jour de ses 20 ans les
personnes l'a gagné depuis non ah oui
c'est vrai des 3 tab aisée la dernière
can et l'érotisme
c'est pas mal là c'est une belle
histoire d'amitié source alors si
c'était à refaire est-ce que vous
prendriez des cours de diction ah ah
mais mais c'est vrai les gens
comprenaient pas tout ce que je disais
au début non il sentait que c'était
drôle forcément pourquoi mais parce qu
en fait je voulais me tais civile joli
si joli inarticulée pas énormément n'ont
elles pas les grisons il n'y a pas
beaucoup de consonnes
et je trouve que ça donnait un style
énorme et je l'imité et je parlais un
peu vite je parlé vite comme haillan et
sans articuler comme si si c'était un
enfer qu'est ce que vous vous referiez
sur un plan chirurgical
est maintenant plus rien parce que comme
je n'avais pas jeunes maintenant j'adore
lire parce que les gens me trouvent
mieux qu'avant donc à l'instant elle
voulait rien changé la wii
j'étais presque beau et presque moche
donc c'est pas facile
j'irai et evans ont maintenant
les rides j'aime bien donc je regarde
jamais pas grande et j'aimais pas
réfléchir j'ai plein de choses et pas de
rides
vieillissez pas j'ai vendu votre âme au
diable ou quoi alors oui à
ce matin
c'était à refaire quelle émission télé
vous ne feriez pas eu d'ajustement marco
fogiel qui était un copain vraiment elle
était des fois il avait le chic pour
vous embarrasser en direct ah ouais
c'est pénible promettait qui avait pas
parlé d'un truc et puis paf il y aller
c'était tu es plus fort que ça c'est un
truc que c'est pas du tout mon genre
si c'était à refaire est-ce que vous
reviendriez ici ce soir on a vu que les
questions les plus classiques sont
passés non je reviendrai pour qu'on
passe à autre chose
j'arrive
savez que vous êtes bon expert ça ce
soir la prochaine fois je me mettrai sur
le sur votre bureau président à côtés de
macha dans l'idée regarde voilà
un vers les pays tiers ben alors
qu'est-ce que abba
il m'a pris pour une [ __ ] alors pour les
autres mais pierre croire à mes
sensations bah oui c'est pour ça que
j'adore jardiner est une robe alors rien
nommé pierre il faut croire en toi tu es
magnifique moi je t'aime je t'aime je
t'aime qui regardent regardez comme il
est foutu regarde regarde redresse toi
voilà mais bien des hanches en avance
hier les jambes seront sur le matos et
va vis et deviens way
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
vous voulez venir et palmade moi
honnêtement je l'admiré j'aurais bien
aimé avoir un temps ollier avec lui je
le dis en toute honnêteté parce que je
suis sûr qu'avec sa sensibilité il
m'aurait montraient des chemins inconnus
mais c'est être pas mort si ces morts
pourquoi vous êtes maintenant mais
d'amoureux là mais non mais il a plus
cette coiffure qui m'excitait quand il
avait 20 ans aie aie ça tient car
[Applaudissements]
en vrac sur les plateaux télé
merci à tous voilà c'était salut les
terriens
soutric
hier
[Musique]
l'ua
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'histoire
merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette émission par le russie la semaine
prochaine à 19 heures salle issia je
sais me toi j'aime tour avant l'émission
salut les gars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux